we're finishing out the safety part of
magmatic - driving which is why we're
looking at how to stop a car how to stop
a car and in particular how long it
takes to stop a car okay two things two
important mathematical things have to
happen in order for a car to stop right
so you're on the road you're at the
wheel and something happens up in the
distance which you realize you need to
stop okay so what two things have to
happen okay number one
well actually number two what you're
leaving yeah number two the class the
brake okay so let me just get that one
now first you're gonna use brakes to
slow down the car I mean obviously if
you just take your foot off the
accelerator
it'll stop but it's gonna take a while
to do that particularly if you yeah but
in order for the car to break something
else happened before that they leave you
have to react the driver I'm gonna do
the up average I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try to do the average reaction times if
you because all of your being incredibly
optimistic the average reaction time for
human beings in a cop trying to stop it
two and a half seconds now let me just
do that two and a half seconds again two
and a half seconds is an incredible than
a point but don't forget you have to see
what's going on you have to think for a
second do I stop or not right like for
example if it's yellow like if you're a
certain distance you are not going to
stop you're going to continue in fact
only hazardous to stop because as a
person to find you who's thinking go go
go go I'm gonna ram into the back of you
right so you not only have to notice you
have to think and then you have to move
your foot from accelerator to break two
and a half seconds
it's an example amount of time I let's
put that down because it's a relevant
detail every two seconds huh boy at the
Olympics less than $2 seconds will cost
your race now in addition to that the
car has to break so this obviously also
takes time and therefore results in
distance what kinds of things do you
think the braking distance depends on
what kind of factors effect okay number
one how fast you're going
clearly really the faster you're going
the longer it will take you to stop the
car okay um you can add a whole bunch of
other things to that like does your car
actually abs just don't really go to
effect because EDIUS is we're not
maintaining control at the cop but I'll
talk about that later you're going to
talk about them how heavy the car is
because a big car versus like a little
Toyota Yaris aren't that different
braking distance but the other main
thing that much more important thing is
the wet oh right because if for example
you're driving in um rain or snow or
sleet that's going to affect the surface
of the road and braking basically works
on friction right more friction brake
faster less friction brake will go so to
stop the car these two things have to
happen and each of them takes time right
the two and a half seconds on average
for this and then however many number of
seconds dependent on these factors okay
so therefore based on these two things
we developed our formula right the
formula for stopping distance the
formula because it depends on these two
themes it has to account for each of
them right so the way we write it is and
you'll find this I'm not going to bother
getting you the program not because it's
literally gonna say exactly whatever
that's right the story this has to
compute it and but the ones that I've
just highlighted you recall on the board
so this first one here which has to do
reaction time we call it very creatively
reaction time distance okay how far do
you travel in that time when all you're
doing is reactive right
you're lucky you're thinking you're
moving your foot to the brake pedal okay
that's reaction time distance and then
there's the brain you've actually hit
the brakes and then you can't start
slowing down but it doesn't happen
instantaneously which is a good thing
because if it did you'd probably fly out
the front window okay yes
something nasty okay now how do I work
each of these bits out our reaction time
distance so remember I said two and a
half seconds right well this is two and
a half seconds depending on how fast
you're going will be love that's right
you'll travel log up or shut up okay now
remember yesterday I asked you I said
okay we did blood alcohol content
remind me by the way of something one
last thing to add on that once we
finished we did by Alcala and then I
said to you okay I'd like you to do that
little bit of work on speed distance and
time it's kind of just reviewing what we
did in rates okay
distance is just how fast you're going
times how long you're going it that's
been right so far we're saying is
distance is speed times time
now you're most because the time scale
we're working on is seconds but will
generally say the speed of a car in
kilometers per hour then just like you
did in your previous assessment tasks
you're gonna have to do some conversion
here I will do an example in a second
they don't demonstrate this but because
this is in seconds you're gonna need
this to be in seconds Robin powers km/h
now then the braking distance because
that braking distance actually has so
many different factors on it okay I'll
be completely honest with you
95% of the time if you have to answer a
question about this they will just hand
you a number they will just tell you the
braking distance is for example I know
the average braking distance for a car
traveling 100
closed Rinella is 67 meters so this is a
zit you've already hit the brakes
it takes 67 meters to stop okay that's a
long-distance litter for hit the brakes
okay
I could take km/h is really fast it's
really really fast and your car is a
very heavy object so they'll just hand
this number to you usually but in the
textbook they do work through like there
are ways you can calculate it okay so
this will be either give it to you
directly like they'll just say here's
the number or they might provide you
with a little formula put some numbers
in - that's the way the the exercise
you're about to do it kind of bottles
that for you Tess okay here's a formula
you can use based on how fast you going
remember you said that was the main
theme okay that'll generate a distance
for you okay now let's up let's use that
example let's say you are a hundred day
clovis per hour and I'm interested in
the stopping distance if I just have a
normal 2.5 second reaction time and the
braking distances will go in that 67
meters when I mentioned to you before
cuz that's what I looked up this morning
okay so how do I work out this is the
this is where most of the calculation is
how do I work out the reaction time
distance if that's the speed my car is
traveling what do I do
think back to the question you did
without those those two names in there
that the two women who are dragging on
and some of us look at their phone for
15 seconds right well this is not
looking for focus 15 seconds this is
just you reacting over to Nahar sec so
shouldn't be as far but how do i do it
what's the first thing that has to be
done to this speed this red
I've got to convert this right that's it
house right and I presume kilometres is
not going to be that useful to be
because in two and a half seconds I
don't travel very many corners I travel
some number of meters so if SEO days I'm
going to convert this 110 close per hour
how many meters in a hundred ten
kilometres a hundred ten does it that's
what so 110 thousand meters is how long
they traveled how far I travel in an
hour but I don't want an hour
what's seconds how many seconds are
there he did hour there are 60 minutes
in an hour and then every one of a
minute has 60 seconds so it's going to
be you can write directly if you like
3600 or I'm going to write 60 times 60
seconds okay and that's 3600 okay so 110
thousand divided by 3600 that's going to
give you some funny decimals could
someone calculate that fool be let's get
say actually we'll just write all the
different places here and just keep that
number at you calculator don't erase it
can someone give okay
so don't you raise that off your
calculator keep it in the display
because that means you're working with
the exact number so every second you're
traveling that far right it's pretty
fast if that's how far I travel in one
second how far I travel in that hope two
and a half seconds where nonreactive
what am I gonna do with this number you
say I'm good at times I'm hot okay so
now I'm working out this some
reaction-time distance it's gonna be mr.
by thirty point five five five five five
times two
okay so the reaction time distance is
equal to it's gonna be between like 60
and it was like 75 so it can someone
give me the economic 17 I'll just do one
decimal place so seventy six point four
meters that's how far I'm traveling
before I even hit the brakes
correct yeah
so multiple and I should say right this
is the average but occasionally a
question will say to you you know
so-and-so is driving and she has a
reactor time of two seconds or so so is
driving he has a reaction time to three
seconds or whatever it is so just for
made the question can we just go with
this yeah you would but I very much
doubt that you know providing yesterday
yeah I said this is how I travel how far
travel every second but I travel for two
to half seconds so I've multiplied this
by two and a half okay let's give me
this seventy six point four but the
number I provided you before as a as a
average was 67 meters to actually dare
hit the brakes and actually slow down so
in order to get in order to get the
total is basically so I'm going to go
with you
in order to get the total stopping
distance I need to take the number you
just worked out this seventy six point
four business and I need to add it to
this other one that's been provided okay
so I'm going to say therefore stopping
distance
seventy six point four meters plus this
sixty-seven that's been provided or
they'll ask you to calculate this with a
formula that's been given to you
76 plus sixty seven a hundred and forty
went three point four meters does that
feel like a lot desist to you yes yeah
because it is because it is which by the
way is why it's so what you know when
you first learn about like where it's a
funeral equity they talk about how far
away you've gotta be from the car funny
when you're driving right and it's not
enough to say oh and that limiting
readers away because this distance is
going to get longer the faster you're
going right so that's why they measure
that seconds rather than it be this
number of colleagues which is what they
used to do once upon time okay
thankfully that will be providing the
questions so I gave that to you today
when you look at various questions
they'll say okay because there's so many
factors where just couldn't give you
okay it's 59 meters or it's a hundred
meters today because it's really wet or
something like that